foreign
quotes is by Dr Marshall Shepard who's a
climate scientist at the University of
Georgia and he says weather is your mood
climate is your personality so weather
is changeable I have no idea what the
weather is going to be like on June 1st
10 years from now but because I
understand the climate of New York I
know that it's likely to be hot it's
likely to be warmer than it was in
January for example so when we talk
about climate we talk about long-term
averages whereas weather is something
that fluctuates on a day-to-day basis
and it's really important to keep those
things separate but at the same time
climate affects the weather because
everything happens against the backdrop
of climate wow so what you're saying is
uh when people if it snows one day right
like it late in the spring it was like
see in climate change people are wrong
because we had a snowfall in late April
or early April and so that's like the
perfect moment to say no you just in a
mood
all right
[Music]
climate change is affecting our weather
and here's how so imagine you have a
paradise and you always have a chance of
rolling a double six that's an extreme
weather event but decade by decade as
the planet warms it's as if it's
sneaking in and taking another one of
those sixes oh sorry another number and
turning it into a six and then another
one turning into a seven and so pretty
soon you're rolling all kinds of double
sixes and even some sevens like you
never used to before and you're like
what is going on that's climate change
and that is but on this on your stereo
system can you turn it up to 11 though
that's really what people think
so in the case of climate change yes yes
okay okay because it is odd when people
say we haven't had floods this High
since 1936 well you had floods that high
in 1936 when no one was talking about
climate change so if the comparison to
the highs today are always indexed to
something long ago what you're really
saying is it's not that it's high
specifically but that we're having a lot
of them and like you said someone is is
low pre-loading the dice so that the six
the double sixes is no longer rare it's
becoming common yeah another way to
think about it is like a baseball player
I think Ryan and then on steroids and
they started to hit a lot more homework
so it wasn't that a home run was
unprecedented it's just that their
statistics changed and that's what's
happening with climate change
help me out here because I'm sure people
are thinking this you're telling me
we've increased two degrees in the last
century or so basically the era of the
modern Industrial Revolution and yet
London is not two degrees warmer than
its average it's way higher than its
average so how does two degrees warmer
on Earth translate into 10 20 30 degrees
higher than average temperatures
anywhere on Earth okay so let's break
that down a little bit so the two
degrees that people talk about that I
just mentioned is the global average
change but you have to remember that the
globe is not warming evenly it's warming
war on land than in the ocean it's when
we're more in the north than in the
South and it's warming most of all in
places like the Arctic so the changes uh
in in New York or in London or in Paris
are more than the two degrees Fahrenheit
that we're talking about in the global
meat so they're about maybe one and a
half two times that so maybe four
degrees Fahrenheit five degrees
Fahrenheit okay so maybe it's away so
maybe you should change the messaging
it's not what the average over the whole
world is if that if because if it's a
huge range in the manifestation of that
average is an average over a wide range
of data a wide range of values then why
not give the average increase at this
latitude we're at the same latitude as
Madrid or we're sorry we New York City
there what the change is at Maine and in
the Arctic why not give those numbers we
so we do right so the Arctic is no you
don't I've not heard you to skip that
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna give it to you
the average change in the Arctic is
about four times the global meat but no
it didn't now Hampden so now listen have
you heard anybody say that Chuck no I'll
tell you here's the problem Gavin so as
a scientist when you look at uh
incremental change you're able to
understand that people are not if you
tell me it's two degrees warmer in this
room than it is in the other room that
means nothing to me it means you don't
give a rat sound I don't care what you
need you're not adjusting the thermostat
right I'm not what you guys need is a
scale that registers in the human psyche
so in one part of the world it's oh my
God hot okay and if we keep going if we
keep going it gets to God damn right
okay
let me
yeah
absolutely right no we're talking about
numbers that really don't mean very much
to people in their everyday lives and so
quite frankly I don't like talking about
these numbers I don't like talking about
two degrees 1.5 degrees to like four
degrees they are very hard to
conceptualize because people are
people's experience of temperature in
their local environments uh during a day
over a season is very different to the
planet's experience of temperature and
so one of the things that uh that I like
to uh to bring up kind of temperatures
is the planet seeing over its history
and one great example is about 20 000
years ago we were in the middle of uh
the The Ice Age and uh you know where uh
where you guys are sitting now uh was
underneath the hundreds of meters of ice
the the glater has extended from the
Arctic Ocean to Prospect Park in
Brooklyn they covered almost all of uh
of North America there's something
similar happening in uh in the UK there
was enough by the way Gavin as a kid I
remember we took a tour of Central Park
right in the middle of Manhattan and
there were escarpments that were
identified as having glacial scarring
destroy Asians right and I'm a kid right
I said Glacier what's the glacier doing
here what a great shirt it was that yeah
no I remember the the mental adjustments
I had to make to embrace what was going
on so the Ice Age was a
forests and trees
Tundra uh The Foreigner is different the
ecosphere is different uh sea level is
different and do you know what the
global temperature change was between
then and now between between
okay how much it was about eight or nine
degrees Fahrenheit okay so that's
helpful I can use that I can use that
yeah so what I like to do is let's call
that an Ice Age unit right so that's
that's that's a big change for the
planet right right right and if and if
you go from where we were to the ice age
that's one ice agent and now what we've
done since the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution is we've gone up
about a quarter to a fifth of an Ice Age
unit and where we might be heading could
be a whole Ice Age unit in the other
direction right right and so we think oh
these are small numbers there but
they're not small to them not to the
Earth planet notices these things the
planets are feels these changes in the
ecosystems in the ice uh in the
temperature and in the extreme
we're seeing the impacts of these things
in the extremes because if you can
imagine uh you know a bell curve and
we're moving the middle of that bell
curve a little bit to the warmer
conditions by you know a couple of
degrees but the things that are changing
the most are out of the ends are out at
the very warmest temperatures or at the
very coldest temperatures so if you're
in the middle of the velcro if you don't
notice it but on the extremes oh my gosh
it's the extreme right right okay and
it's the extremes that make the impact
right nobody cares if a mediocre day is
two degrees four degrees five degrees
warmer than the previous mediocre day
but when you get to 100 degrees plus
every additional 10 degree makes a
difference it makes a difference uh to
how much the the rails are going to
buckle it makes a difference to how much
the airport is going to melt it makes a
difference
we can't land because the airport melted
that's correct
thank you
and that electricity is often generated
by burning coal natural gas or oil be
that as it may that is also in a
fundamental sense solar energy right
okay now you lost me buddy well you've
heard the term fossil yes do you know
where that come where that word means in
Latin or something ah no I would say I
was I don't uh I would maybe like
imprint or something like that like
Buried buried dead that makes sense so
fossil fuels are buried fuels that dig
them up that we dig them up so coal for
example is uh an ancient swamp that's
gotten buried and you know it happens
everywhere in the world the whole
freaking world is lousy with coal and if
you like to worry about things you're
living at a great time because we'll
never run out of coal
Coal everywhere in the world but the
drag the drawback what sucks about it is
burning it is putting all this carbon
dioxide in the air and warming the world
oil is all also ancient buried swamp
right that's under different pressure
and temperature conditions turned to a
liquefied version of oil and natural gas
is created even as we speak in swamps
people talk about swamp gas so about it
smells like goodness wow who knew
30 000 barrels of oil worth are created
every year by burying modern swamps yeah
30 000 barrels ain't no nothing
employing a double negative for for
emphasis when we burn coal oil and
natural gas we are burning ancient
sunlight right stored in the earth's
surface in the Earth's crust hence
indirectly solar power indirectly but it
is uh I don't think we should let this
information again I can see the fossil
fuel companies going hey we're solar
power and so then there's this idea of
burning coal cleanly well even if you
make it not sootful not not very much
soot you're still putting carbon dioxide
in there so you're saying what about
solar energy that lands here every day
Chuck that's what I'm saying I'm saying
why don't we use that if we're in outer
space there's something we like to call
the solar constant the solar constant
yes which is how much energy hits a
square meter of space from the Sun from
the Sun it's 13 1 360 watts per square
meter down on the Earth's surface it's
about half of that it's about uh 500
watts so over the course of a day you
get about six kilowatts per square meter
yeah uh on average and that's enough to
run 60 100 watt light bulbs that's not
bad it's not bad not bad at all at all
but what about powering the whole world
this lovely fabulous computer driven
television show and all your electric
computer machines you have at home and
the we the end the motors on our subway
trains the estimate is we'd need
500 billion square meters of solar
panels converting sunlight into
electricity at about 10 percent
efficiency which is conservative but
reasonable I have solar panels on my
house that are about 15 efficient okay
spacecraft are over 30 percent efficient
but when dust Falls all them blah blah
500 billion square meters we could never
get that much you're crazy Mr hippie
engineer not accepting the importance of
fossil fuel man oh my God it's like you
read my mind 500 billion square meters
is nothing
Arizona's 300 billion square meters oh
wow so if we put solar panels on the
roof of every building every building in
big cities every uh Home Depot Walmart
Tesla factory Chevy factory if we put
solar panels on all of these things we
even have enough electricity to run the
place if we could move it around and
store it we see on the electric
teleprompter area the size of France
that's right now God knows we don't need
France
but France is big but it's not that big
right compared to the whole world yeah
uh look at a map France is there in the
middle it's fine and wait that's the
entire world world you could run it
right now wow and this is why Advocates
of solar power are running around waving
their arms yeah you give us some tax
breaks let's invest in this let's
improve the efficiency let's especially
improve the efficiency of our
transmission lines right so it sounds to
me like we need the solar panels okay
because quite frankly we have the
technology to go ahead and power the
world with zero emissions completely
right if some important details are
worked out transmission and storage
right and I was about to say then it
sounds like we need like some really
cool batteries that will hold all this
stuff together the way to solve The
World's energy problems in my opinion
which as you know is correct it's a big
Time Saver you know Chuck does this
happen to you where you meet people that
don't recognize your Genius you know I'm
gonna say probably a lot more than I'd
like it yes yeah out but anyway along
this line the way to provide energy for
everyone in the world is with not one
thing not covering France or Arizona
with solar panels but everything all at
once we put solar panels everywhere wind
turbines everywhere they fit geothermal
energy where it's uh proper to you or
economical to use if solar power is a
power but and fossil fuels are actually
caused ultimately when this energy is
really a form of solar energy combined
with the spin of the earth that's where
you get wind and how about hydro hydro
is rainfall powered by the sun to make
water vapor evaporate and form clouds
rain and snow it's a big happy party
here on the planet Earth where we have
lit water in three phases and an
atmosphere to breathe well thanks to
solar power our future isn't looking so
dark
foreign
[Music]
let me just lead off by saying as I
understand it unlike the predictions of
Thomas Malthus where he said population
is going to outstrip food supply and we
will starve in Mass numbers he didn't
know what role science would play in the
production of food so as I understand it
Catherine correct me if I'm wrong there
is no shortage of food in the world
there's plenty of food and we can have
food and even up to 10 billion people
but it's the distribution networks of
food and that is the problem right and
so I don't know that climate change
issues or food production issues can
actually solve that problem it's a
political problem isn't it well that's
exactly it we waste in high income
countries we waste 50 of the food that
we produce just by too much on our
plates throw it out rotting in the back
of the fridge ugly fruit you know food
just past its deadline
ugly fruits literally they take it off
the grocery shelf if it's too ugly I
thought this this is Farm Cooperative
that sells ugly fruit I think it's
called something like that and you go in
there it's got some gnarly Tomatoes you
know and and and it's weird how we have
a food aesthetic that has nothing to do
with its nutritional value that's sad
actually it's very sad but what's even
sadder is in low-income countries
they're also wasting about half their
food too but for a completely different
reason because they don't have the
refrigeration in the supply chain to get
it to Market and to distribute it and to
keep it from going back it spoils yeah
then then you have the challenge that
industrial agriculture especially beef
and to a lesser extent other animal
agriculture is responsible for about 14
of our heat trapping gas emissions too
so there's this whole ball of wax time
pack where we need to figure out how to
stop wasting food how to provide food to
the people who need it and how to shift
our agricultural system to one that is
truly sustainable that provides for our
needs and replenishes the needs of the
planet as well look that reminds me of I
saw a comedian joke about this I mean
it's a very serious topic but the joke
made it even more serious he was saying
you know if you had a pen pal from some
other nobody has pen pals anymore or but
pen pal from some nation that is
developing and food is a scarce resource
and you're telling each other about each
other's cultures and so what did you do
last week oh we had we celebrated what
we call Thanksgiving here in the United
States what do you do oh we eat as much
as we possibly can until we on the brink
of throwing up we have to unbuckle our
belt a few notches and then we just roll
onto the couch until we digest it and
then we go back for more what did you do
on your holiday I mean the stark
contrast of our access to food and plus
I don't know any other country that has
so many fitness centers to burn off the
excess food that we ended up eating
never mind the food that we ended up
throwing away
thank you
[Music]
in my experience I agree with you but I
I I tend to have a more sort of
realistic View and that is I've only
ever seen everyone change not all the
time but most of the time when people
change even when there were sort of
conservationists and people uh tooting
that horn they only end up changing when
the act of changing improves their
wallet and or it so consider you know
the movement to stop killing the whales
you know back in the 1800s and then we
stopped killing whales was it because
the movement succeeded no because we
found oil right in the ground and so
economically that whole thing switched
so don't we need an economic solution
here so that the same sandbox can now
make money cleaning things up rather
than getting things dirty well yeah
already do solar energy is now the
cheapest form of electricity we have
ever had in the history of human
civilization on this planet and solar
with storage because of course the sun
doesn't always shine at night doesn't
shine at all at night I'm glad you
caught that because I was gonna be all
up in your face on that one oh well if
you're up in the Arctic no you know we
can get into those but that is actually
cheaper than natural gas already in many
parts of the world and right now I mean
just look at the price of gas in the
United States and in many parts of the
world it is a lot cheaper to have an
electric vehicle over a pretty
relatively short time frame so the
economic argument is already there even
in a market that is heavily skewed
towards fossil fuels the IMF the
international monetary fund not the IMF
that Tom Cruise works for in Mission
Impossible but the other one the real
one they estimate that fossils but
they're both real don't don't denigrate
that movie The Impossible Mission Force
don't don't bad mouth that okay go on
well if they could just fix climate
change for us I would happily call them
real
if it involves fake faces they could
definitely the fake faces that's a fake
face show that's right yes but anyways
the the IMF says that the United States
currently subsidizes fossil fuel use to
the tune of over 600 billion dollars
which exceeds the pentagon's budget so
if you want to follow the money we are
not on a Level Playing Field fossil
fuels are subsidized and that is why
Solutions like carbon pricing which are
endorsed by pretty much every Economist
in the world including the two who won
the Nobel Prize a few years ago that's
why carbon pricing is one of the suite
of solutions a policy solution that we
need in tandem with our Clean Energy
Solutions we need it to work with our
good old-fashioned efficiency Solutions
because efficiency could cut our carbon
emissions in half and save us money and
our nature-based Solutions where we take
carbon out of the atmosphere where we
have too much and we put it back into
the soil coastal wetlands grasslands
ecosystems trees where we want the
carbon put all those Solutions together
and then you have a plan to fix climate
change but you know what to Neil's point
about the
um economics there's a different type of
Economics attached to this issue and
it's social cap it's the idea that
people buy in you know that's and and
that means that they have to first
believe second believe that action is
necessary with some type of urgency and
then third punish those who will not
participate in being the solution so
it's like smoking okay at one point
smoking was everywhere it was cool they
smoked on airplanes I can't believe it
when I see that they used to smoke on
airplanes I'm like where was the smoking
section but the fact is that we don't do
that now if you lit up on an airplane
people would look at you like have you
lost your mind there's an eject button
at the side window but wait so Catherine
so could you give me an example of a
subsidy that we're not otherwise privy
to that amounts to the 600 billion a
year yeah I can give you two types of
examples and this also speaks to the
economic costs so first of all you have
direct subsidies where for example oil
and gas companies are paying you know
Pennies on the dollar for their land
leases the negotiated decades ago and
they're actually pulling from the public
good they're pulling oil and gas and oil
from publicly owned lands and they're
paying a fraction of pittance of what
that is actually worth but then there's
the indirect subsidies and the way we
set up our economic system is we did not
put a dollar sign on externalities which
is the fancy Economist word for things
that we don't price things outside our
economic system and so they didn't put a
dollar sign on all of the heat trapping
gases we produce yet those heat trapping
gases are producing very costly and
certainly valuable impacts on us every
day just to give you one example
hurricane Harvey hurricane Harvey
incurred over 120 billion dollars worth
of direct impacts the indirect impacts
extend for decades afterwards it's
estimated that 75 of those costs would
not have occurred if that hurricane had
been super sized by climate change so
it's a single event you're looking at
over 80 billion dollars from a single
event that's a lot of dollars carbon
really is carrying a cost and until we
incorporate it into our economic system
we have a socialized system which is
kind of ironic for most people because
people think oh those climate Solutions
are socialized no no our current system
is socialized because we all of us as
taxpayers and insurance owners and
homeowners and people who suffer the
impacts of fossil fuel use we are paying
for the price and a few companies are
reaping the benefit
foreign
[Music]
what would be the top five climate
Solutions I don't care how ambitious
they are how do you feel they should be
prioritized above all others thank you
sincerely Jen from Dallas Texas so Kate
it's possible to put Pie in the Sky
goals but maybe they're so Out Of Reach
people get frustrated and then they give
up so maybe there's some Middle Ground
between this is a big audacious goal but
I think it's it's accessible to me so
therefore I will do it so I think that's
a great question
um I also think that physicists are
probably the wrong people to ask that
question too because from our
perspective climate change is happening
because greenhouse gas concentrations
are increasing so how do you stop
climate change you stop doing that and
by the way I was taking recently a diet
book written by a physicist it would
have two words in it it would be eat
less right so
so what do you have you got you have a
top set of goals here um I would say you
know stop burning fossil fuels um
so much number one
um two number two probably eat less meat
or grow meat and fats or eat plant-based
meat turn your diet into one with a
smaller carbon footprint however you
might accomplish it because the day my
color we grow meat proteins and then
you're not raising farm animals to do it
it would have a lower exactly carbon
footprint than vegetarians do if all
that's done exactly so that's
interesting okay three three I mean
maybe this should be number one is don't
vote for people who don't get it oh my
gosh yes
you thought of that what okay right in a
democracy we create our own government
right and so you need an informed
electorate so that the leadership can
has the science literacy necessary to
solve this problem very good okay uh
let's say Electrify everything so you
know a lot of the things that we do
right now
to a clean grip when you do it even if
you're not there yet you have the at
least you're not there yet you built in
the capacity right to take your energy
from any of these other sources without
changing in your setup right yeah so an
electric car is better than an internal
combustion car even if most of that
electricity is not generated from clean
sources so we hope that they will become
generated by Clean sources and you know
again walking biking taking the subway
those are all better than driving
electric car that's not an option for a
lot of people who need to get various
places right right that's so boy you
just made me just imagine a time where
we have a clean smart grid and then
we're a manufacturing clean Technologies
for transportation all the way down the
line it's one big loop of you know Net
Zero yeah production zero carbon carbon
not zero carbon right yeah it'd be a
beautiful thing because you're the
electricity used to make the thing is
clean and then the thing itself is clean
like that's pretty awesome all around
all around
all right